good morning everybody
if i can ask everybody to take their
seats we'll get started
thank you thank you for being such a
quiescent audience goodness me
not usually that way good morning
everyone i'm danielle platka i'm the
vice president for foreign and defense
policy studies at aei
i have to confess to you up front i'm
here playing a purely uh ornamental role
i i was
very graciously asked to introduce this
uh this conference i'm
absolutely delighted that we are able to
do this jointly with the peterson
institute for international economics
as all of you know uh the question of
russian gas and of european security and
of american
foreign policy has really been front and
center getting knocked off the front
pages by worst news from the middle east
uh
from day to day but nonetheless an
enormously pressing
not just short-term but medium-term and
long-term challenge
and one of the reasons that you see me
up here and not
kevin hassett who's our director of
economic studies at aei
is because politics has taken such a
strong
place in the oil and gas environment
in europe and in eastern europe and has
really become a tool for the
russians to exert foreign policies sway
over their neighbors without substantial
resistance from either the europeans or
the united states
when ben zeiker who is a scholar here at
aei
came our way to suggest that we do this
and uh and chatted with leon aaron who's
our director of russian studies i
thought this was really
an important thing for us to turn to
we're going to look at all aspects of
this question not just the foreign
policy but also the economic and energy
aspects and i think this is going to be
a conversation that continues at the
american enterprise institute i know
that we're planning on doing another big
conference
in the fall on this issue when i hope
that we will have some policy progress
to report and i say hope
i'm not actually persuaded that my hopes
will be fulfilled
but i'm going to turn things over now to
desmond blochman a scholar
at the american enterprise institute
who's going in to introduce all of our
panelists
and i want to thank all of you and all
of them very much for being here today
with that yes
thank you danny and good morning
everybody uh
i'm delighted to be moderating this
session
on russian gas and european
energy security
and right at the start i should
complement ben zeiker for having put
this
together this whole seminar together and
uh for the timeliness of the seminar the
seminar couldn't be more timely for a
number of
reasons first in
the context of the ukraine crisis
what we're seeing is russia is not
hesitating to use
oil and gas as an instrument
in achieving its objectives indeed what
we've seen
over the last several months is russia
has increased
the price of natural gas to ukraine by
something like 80 percent it's
insisted on being paid arrears
what this is doing is it's exerting huge
pressure on
the ukrainian economy which is already
deeply in recession it's going to be
requiring
additional international support to keep
that
together worse yet uh is what we're
seeing
uh is that russia is threatening to
curtail supplies of gas to ukraine on
june 17th
they made that kind of announcement and
this has huge significance
in the sense that russia
supplies about 30 percent of
europe's energy supply is
the gas coming from russia
fulfills 30 percent of europe's gas
needs
and this would
since the pipelines all pass through
ukraine
something like half of that gas comes
through ukraine
if there's a disruption in supply this
could have a
very significant impact on not simply
the ukraine economy but on
the russian economy and then the third
reason that i think
that the seminar is timely is uh because
of the events
that we're seeing in iraq uh to which
danny alluded
uh one just has to recall
that iraq is the second largest opec
producer produces something like three
million
barrels a day and more important yet
is iraq is the country on which we're
counting
to supply increased
oil production to meet needs
over the next few years so if we get the
iraq a situation getting out of hand
we're really going to see huge pressure
on international oil prices we've
already seen international oil prices
increased by something like 15
since the beginning of the year uh rent
now is at around about 114 dollars
barrel
this could have a huge impact on the
european economy and the global economy
if those prices go out
so for those reasons uh it seems
that russia really needs that europe
really needs to
reduce its energy dependence
on uh on russia
there would seem to be uh at least three
reasons
why this would be the case first
is that depends on russia if you get
curtailment
of supply from russia that could have an
obvious impact on the european
uh economy the second is more in the
geopolitical sphere
what we're seeing is europe's dependence
on russia for a lot of its energy supply
curtails its ability to act freely to
uh in the diplomatic sphere or sphere of
sanctions
to do something about russia's revenge's
policies uh that we see that
in terms of u.s trying to push sanctions
europe is very reluctant
to go ahead and the third reason is
uh just from a cost competitiveness
point of view
uh europe currently pays something like
three times
the amount that the united states does
for gas
so there's a huge cost disadvantage
uh in which europe is so for that for
those reasons
it would seem clear that europe has to
reduce the dependency
now many ideas have been floated as to
how this could be done
you know they range from europe
investing in gas terminals so that they
can import gas
from alternative sources for europe to
increase the interconnected lines
because what we've got in europe is some
countries
are a whole lot more dependent on
russian gas than others i'm thinking of
the baltics
places like bulgaria slovakia and so on
so that would help developing shale and
gas would be another reason
ben is going to talk about bringing into
production
uh mothballed coal
production facilities in europe
so the many different options but
i'm looking forward very much to hearing
what the panelists
that ben has put together uh have got to
say on this topic
this particular panel will go in
the following order first we'll start
with uh leonie aaron
who's a real russian expert as dennis
mentioned
he heads the russian studies program at
the aei
that produces the uh ai's
russian economic outlook author of three
widely claimed books on russia will then
turn to
anders aslant who's an internationally
renowned
expert not only on russia but on eastern
europe as well unders is the author of
13 books many scholarly articles
and he's also served at different times
as an advisor to the russian government
and to the ukrainian government and then
last
but not least uh ben zeiker
my colleague at a i who's the john sol
chair and is
focused very much on energy and
environmental matters so with that i'll
turn to leonardo absolutely
everybody can see on their agenda that
uh my colleague from the peterson
institute it was intended to
uh was intended to introduce the second
panel and
in fact that was just my
misunderstanding and
he has to depart unfortunately and i do
want to give him an opportunity to say
just a word or two before
we turn to our panel so marcus i'm
terribly sorry he's the
executive vice president of the peterson
institute and their director of studies
so now everybody's going to pay very
close attention because i committed such
a horrible rude blunder at the beginning
so please come up and and take the mic
for just a moment
no thank you very much there's just been
a fair amount of confusion about the
moving parts of this uh of this event
i'm you know in vladimir putin's russia
there's a certain
soviet-era revival to it and i was
feeling like the guy
you know the figure who gets airbrushed
out of the picture um
but i guess we've been inserted back in
um
earlier this month our institution uh
released the new book confronting the
curse the economics and geopolitics
of natural resource governance and in it
colin hendricks and i argue that petra
states countries
whose net oil exports exceed 10 percent
of gdp
engage in militarized conflicts 50 more
frequently than
comparable non-petrol states and while
those results are for oil
it is likely that one might expect gas
for which it is more difficult to access
alternative sources
of supply in case of supply disruptions
and hence increases the effective
efficacy of
embargoes to be even more prone to
politicized abuse
and indeed we find that high prices are
associated with these militarized
conflicts
indeed high prices embolden
the petro states so while the recent
events that dez alluded to
in ukraine are highly regrettable as
colin
hendricks my co-author observed in a
narrow parochial sense vladimir putin
did us
all a great or at least did us a great
service by underlining the topicality of
our work
and indeed we find that russia comes by
its reputation for petro aggression
quite honestly
it was the single most conflict prone
country in our sample
so the so the presumption is strong that
danny is absolutely correct
that um the topic today reflects some
very basic fundamentals
in political economy and
not simply the manifestations of sort of
recent maneuverings between moscow and
kiev
so we are indeed very uh happy
and honored and uh excited
to collaborate with the american
enterprise institute
on this event and which i'm sure is
going to be very important
and uh interesting and i look forward to
the proceedings thank you
thank you very much uh there's danny
on october 24th the year of 1570
the russian czar yvonne iv better known
as the terrible
wrote a letter to a person he called his
dearest sister that
jerry's sister was queen elizabeth of
england
the letter touched on all sorts of
issues in the relations between two
countries
including duty-free trade which iran
alleged english merchants
abused to the detriment of their russian
counterparts
here's how this letter ends we thought
that in your state you are the sovereign
and you yourself
own and maintain your sovereignty and
care for your state's benefits
but it seems that besides yourself other
people
own your state and not just employees of
the state
but simple traders who don't care about
the honor and benefit of the country
but seek only profit and you meanwhile
behave
like a simple maid that you are now
one would think that uh you know this
was just an intemperate
a note in trade negotiations between two
countries not to mention
ivan the terrible's terrible terribly
incorrect sexism
but look at the context in which
this letter the writing of this letter
occurred
ivan the fourth at that time was engaged
in the building of a modern russian
state
and not just any state it was a third
rome
it was the holy russia
the sole remaining embodiment and
guardian of the only correct
christianity which is of course the
orthodox christian
um that state was to become
the defender and protector of orthodox
believers anywhere
and i if this sounds familiar
it should because i intended it to in
the past two years but especially since
the crimean annexation
russian messianism is back russia as a
unique civilization is back
and the defense of ethnic russians no
matter where they are
is also back now uh if we are
shocked shocked
at how 19th century uh vladimir putin's
russia
is think uh of the grandfather
of ivan the terrible ivan iii
who at the very beginning of 16th
century
went to war with lithuania and continued
that war for four years from
1500 to 1503 ostensibly
to defend the russian orthodox subjects
of lithuanian kingdom that he claimed
were
abused by lithuanian authorities
now of course ivan the terrible uh
succeeded in constructing
the russian modern russian state and he
established the russian monarchy
with its seat permanently in moscow so
the duchy of moscow the grand princes of
moscow
became the moscow empire
and the grand princess became tsars
now the costs were enormous including
almost incessant wars in the east and
the west
the devastation of central russia mass
immigration a simple flight of peasants
as far away from moscow as they could
and of course the terror
yet in one's mind on the creation of
this new state
and the monarchy that came with it was
worth the price that price of perhaps
any price
and to me at least the meaning of his
reprimand
to elizabeth is precisely that she
allowed the concerns about economic
benefits
to interfere with the with what
ivan the terrible called the honor and
the benefit
of the state now there are all kinds of
indications
pointing to uh vladimir putin's
intention
to construct a messianic assertive
perhaps even revengeness regime centered
on the recovery
of geostrategic assets lost in the
soviet collapse
and such a regime with vladimir putin as
its president for life i should add
would be inspired by the ideology of
national exclusivity
putin articulated in the uh last couple
of months
centered on four elements russian
orthodox religion
russian ethnicity opposition to the
so-called western values
and the strong authoritarian state
now although the price russia has paid
for this
endeavor has not yet in any way
approached the price of uh even the
terribles building of the uh russian
state
uh nevertheless uh it has been quite
substantial
and most importantly just as it was
as as was the case with uh ivan the
fourth
that price seems to be quite acceptable
uh to vladimir putin
for the same reason it was acceptable to
yvonne uh because the owner
of the state and his plans for that
state
were at stake and they were worse worth
the price
let me just give you a few examples
on on this past
april such a reliable source as the
financial times published an article
under a title gazprom cannot afford
another supply shut
off to ukraine and yet
on june 16th that's precisely what
russia
did now this was just the beginning and
not even
the largest costs um associated
with what to me uh appears to be
a a domestically driven kind of more or
less
permanent low-intensity campaign
of russia against ukraine and we could
go into the details of
what led him called one step forward to
step backwards you know various
maneuverings putin's rhetorical support
for negotiations and the peaceful
solutions which surprisingly
surprisingly
never come to anything real and
apparently ignored by those whom he
pays and trains and directs
in in ukraine now
let me count the ways in which russia
has already uh
incurred substantial economic losses
from its policy in ukraine and the
losses are twofold
one of course from russia's sanctions on
ukraine and by the way
um uh you know ukraine is the third
largest uh uh
recipient of uh russian exports and the
fourth largest
importer to russia uh russia
um the russian
russian exports to ukraine between 27
and 29 billion dollars
or about one 1.4 of russian
gdp it's not a trifle
and yet it appears to be even under a
greater threat
because as putin said last week to the
meeting of the agricultural
producers in stavropol um
he would definitely impose tariffs
at least tariffs if not the termination
of trade
with ukraine after ukraine tomorrow as
expected
is going to sign the associative
agreement
with the european union now this is
extremely important also for this
very touchy political reason russia
imports overall about 40 percent of its
food
from the eu countries and in eighty
percent
uh in the case of larger cities eighty
percent of food is imported putin
complained about that
a few years ago in the speech now the
ruble
is at its record low it's somewhat
rebounded but was it
a couple of months ago at its record low
not just against the dollar but more
importantly against the euro
some staples milk chicken meat
especially meat
went up up to 10 and yet
according to putin the la single largest
apart from the um uh european union the
single largest
um importer uh or exporter of
of me to russia ukraine uh is going to
be
uh subject to additional sanctions let
me move closer to
um other systemic costs
because the the the actual cost of you
know gas and oil
um both in terms of the sanctions that
that that europe may impose at some
point
and in terms of the shut off um of
of the uh exports of gas through ukraine
are clearly substantial but but
that's that's to me is the smallest part
of
of the losses that that that russia is
prepared to
take um the flight of capital
and and the drop in domestic direct
investment both had started before
putin's crimean escapade but undoubtedly
have been increased by the
uncertainty that the markets field by
possibility of sanctions
we had a record outflow of
capital from russia at 62 billion
dollars
last year already this year russia
exceeded that
and apparently on the way to a capital
flight of 130 billion dollars
now 62 billion dollars of last year
was already a record low if you don't
count one year 2008 2009 during the
uh financial crisis where russian
economy shrank by almost eight percent
and yet with all of this russia is
proceeding
with its current policies in ukraine um
the cost of ukrainian russia ukrainian
trade i've already described
russia is ready to sacrifice a very
important um
uh partner for its the recipient of its
exports
and in turn um uh the center
of of uh quite a few of
imports to russia let me conclude on
uh this point
there are moments in nations histories
where where certain leaders that
if they are in place at that time
manage to persuade the people for
whatever time period there is
that there are goals and ideals worth
sacrificing for
and that the nations in those moments
are not guided by
by economic calculations but by fears
hatreds glory pride or anger
and no matter how wrong
that may seem to an outsider
many regimes succeed in extending these
moments in history
uh usually with with considerable
increase in terror
and the monopolistic propaganda succeed
in pushing the economic considerations
uh
to the back of the national
consciousness and
it seems to me as we're calculating both
both what russia may do further
and what we may do to influence
its policy i think it's it's useful to
keep in mind
that vladimir putin at least thus far
has managed to create this moment in
russian national history
and if he has his way that moment
will extend for quite a while thank you
very much
thank you
new technology yeah it's a pleasure
for me from the peterson institute to do
this together with the american
enterprise institute and of course
russian gas today is a big issue
leon has just told you about the
political side of it and i will talk
about
the economic commercial side of
russia as the supplier of gas to
europe and the ukraine and
my bottom line is that a gas prom
is commercially just about the worst
big corporation in the world so
i want to expound on first how bad it
really is
and you will be amazed when you see the
pictures
and then i will touch up on why
it is so bad the leon
developed the geopolitical side i will
also develop another side of it
does it work no
there we go i did it in the wrong
direction that's the problem
so let me start with gas prom's
the first failure a gas from exports gas
almost only to europe and
it has to through pipes
it is just as vulnerable as you can
can be if europe or ukraine
does not buy gas from gas
gas from has nothing to do with that gas
apart from
keeping in the ground gas problem has a
massive
capacity to produce
probably 150 billion cubic meters that
it doesn't use
because it's unable to sell its gas
and as it is today it's almost
completely
uh dependent on europe and then you
immediately say but what about this big
china deal
of 400 billion dollars
well this would amount to 2.5
of russia's exports each year which is
not much
and it would go through a specially
built pipeline to china
which could only be used by china
so china would be a monopsonist against
russia would you as a seller want to be
in that situation
no so this is a very bad deal for russia
and a good deal for china
china will be the price sector because
it has many different sources of gas
and russia that is gas from will be the
price tag i should say that casper is a
publicly traded company
over which the russian government owns
51 then
we look up on the european uh market
and you can see this is total energy
consumption in the european union
it has been stagnant or declining
slightly
from 2003 and it's not going up any
anytime soon
because europe with very high
energy prices that is high energy taxes
and a good energy saving technology
is saving energy rather than increasing
its consumption
of energy a decade a year it was widely
believed that
the superior gas would expand
but it has also been stagnant it has not
significantly increase the share of
european gas production
and major reason for this is of course
this wonderful company
called gas problem
and gas from second failure
it is exactly about gas trump's share
of eu imports falls
steadily and as a consequence
of lacking demand russia has to keep its
gas
underground it's not worthwhile to
produce it
gas pro gas is very difficult
to store if you can't sell it you don't
produce it
and as a consequence of this
its share of global gas gas production
is falling so let me show
a couple of picture what this looks like
for some reason people say that
gas prompt supplies
one third of eu's imports of gas
which is not true this is eurostat
statistics
and measured in energy content and it's
only 25
and it's falling steadily so instead you
can see
that uh norway about which new
body talks is increasing its
its share and subscribe
the dependency of europe on
russia for gas imports are highly
exaggerated
the market is declining and gas from
share is steadily declining and
if we move over to global
natural gas production it's not bad
better you can see here that russia's
gas production today
is not bigger than it was in 1990
this is as stagnant an industry as you
can find
and consequently russia's
share of global gas production
has declined from 30 percent in 1990
to today about 17
and what about the value
of russia's gas export
here you see that picture
it is also stagnating
admittedly 12 of russia's exports
is not little and this is almost 70
billion dollars
but it is not not
all about important uh either
oil is far more important for russia oil
is
the old dominant export item
and then let me happily move on to
gasprom's
third failure not
only is gastron losing out abroad
it's also losing out at home because
russia actually has a certain gas market
even if it shouldn't be exaggerated
so the two companies that are taking
market share from russia
is nova tech which is a crony company
it's again not the
tim chenko is a major owner who's one of
the four cronies but the u.s
treasury has a sanction
and rosneft is a the state company now
preferred
by putin and nova tech is a very
well-run company by any standard
rosneft is a politically no more
powerful company than
than a gas problem and nothing is as
badly run as
a gas problem so we are losing out
but most of all gas promise losing out
in in ukraine ukraine has been
russia's gazprom's
second biggest market sometimes the
first biggest market in terms of volume
and in terms of a price
competing with germany and now you are
seeing that the
gas problem in its commercial wisdom is
the catholic
market out and here you can see the
how the gas problems share of total
gas production in in russia is
is declining
and then we come to the worst failure
that is gas from commercial failure its
market capitalization
has fallen by three quarters since may
2008
when it hit 369 billion dollars
today it's lingering at around 95
billion
dollars and this is what it looks um
on
on a graph and then we have four more
gas from failures that are just taking
passing
gas prom has of course neglected the u.s
shale gas
revolution which is for long denied
was true and just in case the gas
problem is strongly sponsoring all the
environmental movements in europe
so that they can work for the
prohibition of exploitation of
shale gas in europe they've been
successful for example in the czech
republic and
bulgaria and
it also ignored the global lng
revolution it missed out on the chinese
market
until now and it has
underestimated eu competition policy
that
it didn't think was had any truth which
now turns out
to to be wrong and
here you see how russia is
the 10th biggest producer of
lng in the world and you might ask why
russia is producing so little lng
but let me tell you that is the wrong
question the right question would be
why is russia producing lng and the
answer is easy
because shell royal dutch shell
had a concession on
sakhalin to develop lng it was not cast
from itself
that came up with the idea and then
gastrum strong armed himself
into that project and demanded half of
it
so this was through a nationalization
of half of the shells
project and then i come to the point
what gas problem is really about
liam gave you his answer which i do not
quarrel with but i put it as number two
geopolitics
i put something else on the first
place namely generating personal
revenues
to kremlin officials and
by my calculations that's about 23
billion dollars
or through overpricing you should
probably add
asset stripping as an additional
factor but let me give you the simple
uh gas from financials this is what
all share analysts look upon
and the pre pit picture is not pretty
the capital expenditure for the last
three years averaged 46 billion dollars
according to the better banks analyst
that is
35 billion dollars too much
11 billion dollars would be perfectly
sufficient
so then you wonder what obvious
the net profits are only 40 billion
dollars a year
so this means that russia russia's gas
problem
but has had the largest net profits in
the world
at times more than exxon mobil
it has no free cash flow
so what you do with the money you take
it
which is of course a very sensible
attitude to money
so gastron does this by building
unnecessary pipelines at three times two
higher costs
and this overpricing over 23 billion
dollars
to crony companies is have now been
sanctioned
by the u.s most of these 18 companies
crony companies about the united states
have sanctioned are
crony companies belonging primarily to
um
gennady timchenko and to arkady and
boris
rothenberg and they are building
pipelines
for gas prom that have no commercial
value
and we are selling them at a massive
price
you heard something similar with sochi
olympics
there are 51 billion dollars where but
his name's of assesses about the 30
billion dollars
was at least went to corruption
gasprom is doing this every year
this is the greatest money machine in
the world
to put in and friends so
how do we call such a company well we
don't really call it a company
we call it an organized crime syndicate
so gas prom should be seen as the
greatest organized
crime syndicate in the world and
therefore
commercial goals are not very important
and while geopolitics
are important as a secondary secondary
goal so let me just show you the gas
from
financials and you can see here that
for each year capital expenditures which
is how you tap money from the company
exceed profits and you can also see that
the capital expenditures
are increasing wave
with the profits so for example for
2011 a gas prom had planned
to begin with 27 billion dollars of
capital expenditure
but when they get got more profit what
you do
you build more pipelines but if you
shovel more money out through the door
which is the real activity and the total
investment ended up at 53 billion
dollars
were not investment by capital
expenditure the money they threw away
at their near and
dear so what does this look like
here this is how it typically happened
alexey miller was hero of
gastron comes into putin and putin all
asked what new pipeline can you promote
proposed today and miller julie has a
map with him so that we can look upon
what pipeline he
suggests that but
the pro the question you of course ask
in the end is
do they have any vision can you really
con
continue with this mass corruption
building pipelines because you can get
two thirds kick back on them rather than
doing something that is useful
for the country so
what is my advice to ukraine after this
slight
analysis of gas problem hang in there
don't give up
cancel the 2009
agreement with russia which gave russia
all benefits and ukraine only
obligations
this must be ended and the european
union
should insist here on creating
a normal market at present
what russia offered as a price
for the first quarter of this year 268
dollars per 1000 cubic meters
while i think uh abdiela russ now pays
169. you know a slight difference
depending on how close to the kremlin
you are and
two days into april russia all of a
sudden
raised the price to um uh
385 dollars and then
one day later they increased it to 485
dollars
so this is the per 1000 cubic meters all
the measurements
so this is a totally politicized and
arbitrary
business and this cannot be accepted in
any any civilized
business connections so my view is that
the gas problem should simply be
sanctioned
as an organized crime syndicate on
elementary money laundering rules
rather than on a political laws thank
you
thank you anders uh ben
okay
quite a viable option for uh
increasing european energy security
rather quickly which
not many people talk about because it
seems to be unmentionable in polite
society
but i think it's worth thinking about
nonetheless so a few data on the
european union and russian natural gas
and i have a slight issue with uh
anders numbers in fact i think it is the
case
unless i'm looking at the wrong data
sets that
relative to 2012 and 2013
uh russian gas at about
um 14 a little over 14 billion cubic
feet a day
was 31 not nearly 24
of eu gas consumption between 2012 and
2013
eu gas imports from russia increased by
a fifth
while imports from norway declined by
about four and a half percent
and uh from north africa there was a
twenty percent decline to only six
percent of uh
eu uh consumption among the eu
28 uh here is just a chart
from that i lifted from the economist
after checking the euro gas
numbers and these numbers are correct
for 2012
uh at 24 for the eu as a whole but in
fact in 2013
that in that market share for russia and
the eu
increased pretty substantially
uh so unlike the case for crude oil
gas dependence matters there's no such
thing as an embargo in the world oil
market
and you're all i think quite familiar
with this argument in fact though
with natural gas traveling through
pipelines
predominantly in localized markets uh
threats
are much more viable um dependence
matters
under a number of conditions when
non-economic incentives such as those
presumably driving putin's behavior in
influence gas supply behavior when
contracts are hard to enforce when
contracts with sufficiently long terms
are hard to negotiate etc etc
and in fact over half of
russian gas travels through
two major pipelines transiting
through ukraine and that is something on
the order of 15 or 20 percent of the gas
consumed in europe
and so various scenarios that we're all
familiar with are wholly plausible
there can be cuts in russian deliveries
you the ukrainians
can divert supplies of themselves so gas
dependence really does matter in this
context
the question then becomes is europe have
any options in the short term any
leverage of itself
and i think the answer is yes based upon
review of the trade literature
discussions with industry insiders etc
western europe has something a bit
over 21 000 megawatts of
coal-fired capacity that have taken
offline
in the last decade or so for various
reasons
and so let's just conduct a conceptual
experiment
in in 20 last year the eu generated
about 182 billion kilowatt hours
electricity with gas
and that works out to about 3.9 billion
cubic feet a day
remember recall that russian gas has
about a 31 percent market share
in the eu if we just assume
proportionality
we get about 1.2 billion cubic feet a
day of russian gas being used to
generate electricity
well suppose we took out of that 21 000
plus megawatts of idle
coal-fired capacity and and
fired up 10 000 megawatts of it to
replace an equal amount of gas-fired
capacity so if we use some standard
assumptions
that coal newly
new coal-fired capacity returned to the
grid would replace about 75 billion
kilowatt hours
of gas generation using about 1.6
billion feet a day
which is more than 10 of eu
imports of russian gas which as i
mentioned a moment ago
is a little over 14 billion cubic feet a
day
so how much would that matter well if we
if
given that annual eu spending on russian
gas
is roughly 53 billion so russian
revenues would fall by about 6 billion
per year some even assuming no
downward price effects now would that
affect russian policies you know i'm
inclined to agree with
leon that putin is driven by a very
different set of objectives
and so it probably i think would not
affect russian policies very much but i
think that's also
kind of a side issue the more central
question here
is is the reduction in the russian
ability to engage in opportunistic
behavior to make threats
and it seems to me that that that adding
coal-fired capacity and replacing
gas-fired power power generating
capacity in western europe
would have the effect of reducing the
ability
of of the russians to deliver
threats you know either with or instead
of
gas itself so let's assume
that each thousand megawatts of
uh eu coal capacity would require
both scrubbers and catalytic converters
you know my preferred
objective to be honest about it is
simply to let the prevailing winds blow
the effluents into russia
but that aside let's just suppose we
adopted u.s
type environmental controls that would
cost
roughly 350 million for each thousand
megawatt plant so there'd be a one-time
cost of about three and a half billion
and those retrofits would take something
on the order of one to two years
at least in principle putting aside
political delays
and and all the rest now what about
greenhouse gases you ask
if we assume again a replacement
of gas-fired power with equal amount of
coal-fired power
net greenhouse gas emissions would
increase
by about 80 percent on on a per
megawatt-hour basis
the increase would be or per megawatt
hour
the increase would be about four tenths
of a metric ton again per megawatt hour
so for 75 billion kilowatt hours or 75
million
megawatt hours that increase in
greenhouse gas emissions would be about
30 million
metric tons each year how important is
that well global
greenhouse gas emissions depending on
which data set you look at are
between 35 and 45 49 billion
metric tons per year and so assume
either figure a coal gas substitution
policy implemented by the eu
as i've just described would increase
global emissions by less than one-tenth
of one percent annually
if we run that increase through the
national
center for atmospheric research climate
model which is used by everybody who
works in this area
uh the temperature effect in 2100 would
be less than
seven ten thousandths of a degree even
under the highest i pick assumption
about the sensitivity of temperatures
the increases
in greenhouse gas concentrations just as
a point of reference
the standard deviation of the surface
temperature record is about 1 10 of a
degree
so that increase would not be measurable
so
in conclusion note that that european
shifts toward coal
already are taking place german coal
consumption has increased
13 since 2009
partially due to the economic recovery
from 2008 partially as renewables have
proven rather disastrous economically
partially in the wake of the 2011
nuclear shutdown in germany of about
8 000 megawatts and and further planned
reductions
of 12 000 megawatts by 2022 in the uk
the increase in in coal consumption is
22
i think this trend in europe is likely
to continue
given u.s industrial access to
inexpensive gas which will
confront europe with increasingly
unfavor unfavorable
industrial competitive conditions
now again a notional
eu electric generation shift in favor of
coal as a substitute for gas
is not very fashionable but i think it's
an option worthy of far more attention
than it's received
so thank you very much uh
thank you ben and thanks to all the
panelists for
really provocative and interesting
presentations
before i turn it over to questions which
i'll do shortly
perhaps i could just ask a couple of
questions
to get some clarity as to where we're
going in
this russia ukraine european
crisis the question that i'd have
to the panels would be how do they see
the prospects
for any resolution uh to the
russia ukraine uh crisis you know if i
understand
uh leon correctly uh putin is motivated
by
matters other than economics so does
this lead us to a very
dismal conclusion as to where we might
be going
in the crisis i guess the second
question i'd have
is what is the appropriate response
by the united states and europe in terms
of sanctions you know if these sanctions
aren't going to uh do much good in
slowing them down you know should they
nonetheless
pursue it i would have thought that the
sanctions
would have uh great costs
to the united states and europe in the
sense that we're not dealing with
iran here we're dealing with a country
that is really quite an important part
of the global economy with
strong financial linkages so
that would be my second question you
know the last question
uh i guess would be directed at unders
is
do i understand him correctly in
thinking that
russia doesn't have huge leverage over
ukraine you know in the sense that it is
its major
uh exporter you know they can just
proceed as they're doing an
extraordinary way just raising
the gas price and threatening to cut it
off it would
seem to me that ukraine is
in a very weak position uh in respect
to russia but you know i'd refer
to to an expert on on this matter
so maybe yeah if we take it up just take
those three questions and then we'll
turn it over
well at least at least on the on the
first two uh there's excellent questions
uh what next in ukraine again uh
if if uh my perception is correct and
and
you know i'll be happy to be wrong here
for the sake of russia and ukraine
um russia's behavior or let's call it
what it is a
a low-intensity war on ukraine
is a corollary of its domestic political
imperatives in other words
to build the kind of regime that
vladimir putin is building
with himself as president for life you
do
need on this kind of
kind of on and off low intensity
conflict you know
this is this is a not news this is
authoritarians in history starting from
you know sparta and nation greece and
all the way to saddam hussein and and
and and everybody else um not to mention
stalin i mean you need
you need a hostile environment
to point to both as as an excuse for
um in definitely uh lowering standard of
living which you're already seeing in
russia
see more of this and also for
uh the boost to the popularity of the
leader who
is then positioned by the monopolistic
propaganda which we already have in
russia as far as the television is
concerned
as the the defender against all those
dark forces that are
that are gathered on the borders of the
of the country
and so i think the pattern was settling
in in ukraine is something like this
um russia confronts ukraine with a
horrible
moral dilemma either either
admit foreign a foreign country's
sovereignty over your territory
or try to reclaim the sovereignty which
will indef which will definitely lead
undoubtedly lead to bloodshed including
civilian deaths
and so so the situation is like this the
the so-called
the so-called rebel or separatists who i
don't think you know
go to the bathroom without checking with
putin first um
attack um a high a high uh symbolically
high value
um target say like they did in in
um airport in donetsk the ukrainian
force is trying to retake it
there are casualties on both sides but
also also um
because this is urban warfare and
deliberately so by moscow
um casualties among the civilians
there are there are there's hugh and cry
in moscow ukraine is accused of
killing and butchering russian speakers
ukraine stops it announces a unilateral
uh
ceasefire putin rhetorically definitely
supports that unilateral ceasefire
ostensibly gives the water to the
separatists to stop
nothing of course happens and then and
then there is another attack and we
we're back to where we were and i think
this is the pattern which i think is
going to
go on um unless putin decides that
you need to um to
cash in that chip uh in exchange and i'm
talking about the southern
and eastern provinces of ukraine in
exchange for so-called federalization of
ukraine which in effect will make those
provinces
uh russia's protectorates formerly
within ukraine but culturally
ideologically
economically and politically uh russia
so
so that i think i'm afraid that where
we're settling with ukraine now in terms
of sanctions um i didn't mean to say
that that russia is impervious to
sanctions
when i say that that its behavior is is
rooted in something rather than
economics and it's something
goes to the center of regime's
perception of itself legitimacy and
national pride
you could still influence this behavior
but what we need to remember
is that we if this analysis is correct
the sanctions will have to be directed
not against specific politics
policies of the regime but against
regime's legitimacy inside the country
and and they will have to be for
extremely
long term i mean five ten years
uh because uh because otherwise you
cannot possibly get
to to uh with any effect to influence
uh the behavior of russia given that you
know superficially known economic
factors
i mean superficial economic factors do
not influence it let me just give one
number that i forgot to give
uh russia's annexation of right off the
bat russia annexation
uh russia's annexation of crimea costs
between two and three billion dollars
there is a bridge that's being built
accord uh you know uh direct bridge
um to um to crimea from russia that's
probably another
billion dollars given the over charges
and corruption
and then finally putin's promises to
raise um pensions sometimes by
factors of 203 uh salaries invest in
ukraine
i mean invest in crimea and so on and so
forth are likely to
add even more to this bill to pay for
the annexation of crimea this year
russia is essentially arrested
the private non-state portions
of people's pensions you know there is
an option to invest in private
uh and according to um alexey olukay who
is the minister of finance
uh recently uh that amounted to 243
billion rubles
essentially taken out of of of people's
private accumulation
and spend on crimea that's about 8
billion and i think the costs are
mounting
so so so these are the length to which
this regime
is likely to go on in order to continue
its policies on ukraine
so so if you if you do decide to go into
sanctions
do it with no expectations of a quick
return and
and stay there for a long haul thanks
thank you uh i'll start on your second
point which is really
the european union the european union
is strongly underestimated both in this
city and in moscow
when it comes to competition policy in
competition policy
the european commission holds its own
and that's the only area where the
european commission
decides independently and
the european commission has started a
case
against gas from about two years ago and
this is the biggest competition policy
ever and remember that microsoft and
intel among others
have been forced to pay fines of over a
billion dollars
when being
punished by the the european con
commission
watched the european commission
tentatively asked
for in fines from gas trump is 15
billion dollars
and they ask for a complete change of
the business model and this is highly
relevant for
ukraine moving to the first point
the 2009 agreement between russia and
ukraine is absolutely against the
current eu competition policy
the first problem is that the prices in
it
are oil linked and
gas prices heavily linked on the
on the world market from oil
and therefore
stockholm arbitration court regularly
uh goes against in its verdict's
gas prom to the tune of several billion
dollars
each year as various european
gas companies quietly eschew gas from
uh and win secondly this
formula for ukraine is clearly flawed
since the ukraine is supposed to
pay higher prices than anybody else so
somehow the ukrainians were cheated on
it a third problem
is that ukraine committed itself to a
large volume of imports that it doesn't
need
according to this take and pay pay
clause
that means that even if you don't take
the gas
you are supposed to pay for the full
volume
at the full price and this is also
regularly being thrown out in the
stockholm arbitration
court and fourthly
this agreement contains a prohibition
against the
re-export which is also against the eu
competition rules on top of that
it has a fixed price for
transit through ukraine but there russia
commits to new volume
so it's a totally uh biased agreement
against the ukraine it's also different
timings on the different clauses from
one to ten years
so of course the russians insist on
maintaining this and it should be thrown
out
and i think that the eu which acts here
through
eu energy commissioner gunter ottinger
as a mediator will through it out
the price is not such a big deal
ukraine is now accepted 326
and russia wants a 385 dollars
per 1000 cubic meters and make it 350
dollars and
both sides will be okay that could be
possible probably should be
a bit lower given how the market
develops as we have
discussed and then of course ukraine
should pay barriers
but you don't pay the ebay iberias
before you have
settled the price so ukraine has taken
a volume of gas in april and may where
there was never any agreement on the
price
so that is up to be decided before that
ukraine of course you're not uh
pay barriers so and
can ukraine manage this yes ukraine can
manage perfectly well
without taking any guess probably until
the end of this year
uh because ukraine has
large volumes of gas
stored and ukraine
produces 40 of its gas needs
in any case on top of it ukraine should
now undertake a big
gas reform that has been uh agreed
in the imf standby agreement of uh
of of march so it's
ukraine should cut its uh consumption of
gas by 40
in the next say five years and meanwhile
it could increase its
own production by 50 percent uh both
through conventional or
shale gas and in that case ukraine does
not need any
imports whatsoever so russia's in the
medium term russia's position is
extremely weak
in the very short term it's also weak
but
uh in a year's uh
time or so when it comes to the next
winter
then russia has a stronger possession so
russia has an interest of getting uh
this um settled uh on the
the overall issue my view is that putin
has strongly overplayed his hand
with regard to ukraine and
think of it like this that russia's gdp
today
is six percent of nato gdp which is the
relevant entity
if you are then starting a war of
expansion you are in a very weak
situation you can compare with nazi
german 1938
it was 38 of a european economy
so you can say that hitler was much more
rational
going on the expansion war than
then vladimir putin then of course you
may say that
perhaps putin is not doing an expansion
war
and when i say sorry
and crimea prove prove the point
if you have started on that track you're
not likely
to stop what we are seeing now in
donbass to my mind
seems to be a mess and it seems as if
putin has not decided what to do
and i hear from the ukrainian government
that they think that he
had planned to do this in march 2015
when they feared that yanukovych would
lose the presidential elections
and that they were intent on intervening
then
but he had only the plans for crimea
clear and set
and not for the rest of the country
this blew up on the trade union
building in ajessa seems to have stopped
one part of the intended russian
expansion towards
transnistria and now it's limited uh
to donbass it seems to be a big mess
and the russian public statements
that go against every
sense of truth means that
it's very difficult to take any russian
public statement seriously
and with the annexation of crimea
russia has violated half a dozen of
major
ratified international treaties so what
meaning would it make to have another
treaty
with a government that persistently
violates even ratified treaties
thank you okay well i'll keep this
i'll keep this short and of time i'm
rather dubious about sanctions frankly i
don't think they work very well without
uh enforcement uh but
pardon me uh
the light's on okay
uh i i really don't think sanctions will
work
uh notice the french are just just now
delivering warships
um i i really cannot believe
particularly given in in a
time period when the european economies
are not growing very well
they will impose sanctions or costs upon
themselves
in order to achieve lower gas prices for
ukraine doesn't strike me as all that
plausible
um i i really do believe
i i think i disagree a bit with with
anders
um i think at least in the short term
uh russia does have a good deal of
leverage over
over ukraine uh regardless of the
the sins that can be laid at the at the
feet of gasprom
and um and i believe a much
more fruitful policy for the u.s and for
europe would be to find
alternatives both in the short run and
in the medium term
to the use of russian gas
re-firing up coal-fired capacity et
cetera et cetera
exporting u.s lng as quickly as possible
and all the rest
i don't see really much of a much
alternative to that
and that would have the salutary effect
not only of helping europe and ukraine
but of weakening our friend vladimir
putin in the medium term
thank you let me open up two
questions
if you could just identify yourself and
i'm barry wood an economics columnist
i'd like to
ask about mr putin's visit to vienna
this week
he signed this south stream pipeline
deal with the austrians and the the
italians the bulgarians the serbs
they all seem to want that is it
significant that the
south stream pipeline seems to be going
ahead and do you see any prospect that
the european union
given that division is going to move
towards
sanctioning the russian gas industry
thank you
bulgaria and serbia were forced
out of their commitments to south stream
by the european commission this
agreement yesterday in vienna really
came as a big surprise
that austria would go that far
so this is a big fight within the
european union
and my suspicion is that
it will not succeed as i said
the main purpose of self-stream is for
president putin to go around to various
countries and give
personal amounts of money
to certain political leaders and
uh as prime minister he did little
travelling
apart from on the balkans to visit
certain
politicians in order to promote the soft
stream so
when the gasps from builds pipelines
it's very personal we see for example
with gerard schroeder
and on north stream and uh
also a former finnish prime minister
pablo
it's good to have good polit top
politicians
or former top politicians on it in the
balkans you
don't need to go to former politicians
you can go to current politicians
and provide them with they are what they
most want
money we can't prove exactly who has
done what
but there are lots of suspicions
out and this is not an acceptable
activity
i think that there will be serious legal
issues uh raised
because of such suspicions
and um the european uh commission in
this
case is the energy commissioner
interrupting her who is
quite tough and has a
relatively strong mandate so i don't
think that this is the conclusion of it
even if it was a big turn in favor of
russians we saw yesterday
we've probably just got five minutes so
let me just group a few questions
sir
thank you this is to leon aaron uh
you've expressed the
idea that russia is acting now just how
it acted in 1570
and on the other hand demarcus noland
said that
he expounded the idea that petroleum
states act in a particular way
so is russia acting more like it always
does or is it acting like a petroleum
state
thank you
um let's
start the back then
i'm bronchoterrozic a former
commissioner on the u.s federal energy
regulatory commission
so my question is about the pipelines
historically when the original contracts
were written between
russia and the european union there was
no other supply of gas and so
it was a bundled contract of combination
of delivery
and uh gas at the border and taker pay
was common it was common in this country
but it was take or pay to finance the
pipeline more than to
finance the construction my question is
uh if you have a russian pipeline coming
to the border
of a european union country
at the border how does the european
union extend its authority
into the into russia to require them to
unbundle a pipeline
couldn't they just treat the point of
entry as if it was a gas
well and and proceed with negotiations
there thank you
thank you just take one last question
ah thank you i'm alex pimena uh with the
voice of america
and my question i refer to the sphere of
political analysis don't you think that
given all these developments
around ukraine and in ukraine and
between russia and ukraine
um one should really very seriously
excuse me seriously revise uh
the understanding of the very nature of
the russian
regime that developed within the last
20 years thank you
all right let me take you quickly the
first the first questions on
because they're very similar i think i
think
that's exactly right um uh uh i think
there are signs that putin from his
re-election on
uh is revising some fundamentals of the
state
it's revolt it's evolving from a
relatively soft
internationalist authoritarian state to
a much harder
more traditional authoritarian state
where where the opposition is now not
just marginalized
but but also uh
intimidated and and stigmatized
attack on the civil society well you
know all those laws except uh
adopted after his re-election much more
oppressive
but also messianic and aggressive um and
the basis like i said the basis
putin pretty much declared that that
russia is a unique civilization
and it has its own laws and it has its
own mission in the world
and it's it's based on on on these four
whales
of russian ethnicity uh orthodox church
uh strong authoritarian state um uh
and and so and so this is this i think
is where he's taking russia and it's
definitely a
market evolution of the regime um and
and i think the crimea and the ukrainian
situation there
partly was caused by the events outside
putin's control
but as anders interestingly confirmed it
was a state that
pretty much was prepared to do it
already so so
i think it is a watershed and i think my
biggest concern
frankly with all you know due respect to
ukraine
is not what's happening between russia
and ukraine but what's happening inside
russia
thank you first the question on
pipelines you're of course right that
the european union has no authority on
russian territory
but gasprom owns
half of the pipelines in rather many
countries
in in the area in between
and
at least ukraine has subscribed to the
european uh energy community i think
also moldova in georgia and that means
that they
accept the whole com energy competition
policy of the european union
they have committed themselves to
dividing transmission and
and the production of various kinds of
energy so the european union can push
hard in that fashion and
against from complaints massively
including president putin himself that
this is
confiscation of of gas trump's property
in the various eu countries where they
own
pipelines on the question of revise
the nature of the russian regime i would
argue that we are seeing
four different putin regimes the first
one
during his first term was authoritarian
but fully market liberal
the second from 2004 to 2007
was state capitalism uh the informal
third term
was asset stripping focusing on taking
as much as possible out
of a state company to the team corrupted
barcode companies
and then i think that what we are
increasingly seeing now
is sheer arbitrariness i showed
intentionally this picture of
putin and miller because this is how
decisions are made now
they are not made by the government the
government is irrelevant
but you have certain ordeal
or the railway chief
de konin coming to putin with
a multi-billion dollar proposal and
putin without
going through proper procedures signs
off on it
so this is really the worst kind of
arbitrariness the picture i'll show you
this was the
yakuza um the far east
gas project which costs at least 55
billion dollars
probably 65 billion dollars
or more and this is decided like this by
uh putin now
so this is what happens when you're
going down
yeah just very briefly um the only petro
state in the world that matters
is saudi arabia and their behavior and
russian behavior and natural gas markets
very different
and even in terms of russia russia's
behavior in the world oil markets very
different from this behavior in the gas
market
in europe simply because of differences
in the degree to which they can engage
in opportunistic behavior
i think the take or pay problem is
really much less important than a lot of
people assume
for from a consuming nation the
standpoint gas
not taken today can be taken tomorrow
and so the only real issue is the
interest on
on the early payment and that i think is
a good deal less important than a lot of
people
um a lot of people assume
thank you very much uh i think we'll now
move to the second panel
but beforehand uh i'd just like to thank
our panelists for what i thought was a
great discussion
okay why don't we get started so we can
get out on time for the game
my name is mark perry and i'm a resident
scholar at aei
and a professor of economics at
university of michigan in flint
i'd like to thank my colleague ben
zeiker for kind of being the driving
force behind
the event today and also thank the
peterson institute for co-sponsoring the
event
so we're switching now from the
political dimension to the policy
dimension
and we've got a panel of three speakers
i'll introduce them briefly and then
they'll
share their thoughts with us tim bursma
is a fellow of the energy security
initiative and the foreign policy
program at the brookings institution
and his research focuses on energy
policy coordination energy security
gas infrastructure and regulation
resource security resource scarcity
and unconventional natural gas
extraction before becoming a full-time
academic researcher tim spent five years
in the private sector working as a
corporate council to the electric
electricity production sector in the
netherlands
then we have gary hufbauer who's been a
senior fellow
at the peterson institute since 1992
he was formerly a director at the
council on foreign relations
professor of international finance
diplomacy at georgetown
deputy director of the international law
institute at georgetown deputy assistant
secretary
for international trade and investment
policy of the u.s treasury
and director of the international tax
staff at treasury
he's written extensively on
international trade investment and tax
issue
issues and has co-authored 16 books
then gary schmidt my colleague is a
resident scholar at aei
and co-director of aei's maryland ware
center for
security studies and director of aei's
program on american citizenship
previously gary was the staff director
of the u.s senate
u.s senate select committee on
intelligence and executive director of
president reagan's foreign intelligence
advisory board
gary's security work focuses on
longer-term strategic issues that affect
america's security at home
and its ability to lead abroad while his
work in the area of citizenship focuses
on challenges to maintaining and
sustaining a strong civic culture in
america he's written
and co-authored at least six books and
has a phd from the university of chicago
so we'll start with tim
great thank you thanks for the kind
introduction and thanks for coming back
i appreciate that you know some of you
have left because indeed
in this country everybody believes they
can win uh as my fiancee's portuguese
i'm sure you'll appreciate that i don't
believe you can win
but but i wish you all the best for the
game uh
i've uh so i'll say a few words first uh
about what i'm working on at brookings
at the moment and what is
what is relevant of course to the debate
you're having today
thank you pardon there are slides yes oh
there
these are not them are they somewhere in
the queue or how does that work
there they are yes good thank you uh
so uh
let me say a few words about myself so
this presentation want to say a few
words about what i'm working on now
i want to say a few words about energy
security in europe
then i'd like to say a few words about
where energy policy in europe stands
today
and i'll give you an outlook and that
will be the conclusion at the same time
um so uh my personal background was
touched upon earlier so i don't have to
mention it
at the moment at brookings uh we're
working on a number of projects that i
think are
uh relevant uh uh in in view of uh the
debate we're having today
uh one we're doing uh a number of
scenario studies
uh about the future of gas supplies in
europe and
we're working with the energy research
institute in moscow
and one of our senior non-resident
fellows who has a decades-long
career in the european gas industry our
our main hypothesis is that uh and we're
i think we are very close to the data
that uh that ben referred indeed russian
gas will be very competitive
in europe uh at least until the end of
the decade uh
that is to say that natural gas in
general we will be less competitive than
coal of course so
the share of coal as was referred to
earlier has been rising and will
continue to rise at least until the end
of the decade
and some people believe even longer we
believe that of the natural gas
used in europe an increasing share will
come from russia as indigenous
resources are declining as the ability
of norway to increase its production are
limited
and as production in algeria has
declined dramatically
and moreover there is as some of you
will know
a very significant amount of
reclassification capacity already in
place
europe can import about 160 bcm today
so those plants are there they're
heavily underutilized some of them are
10
or so uh one of them is the gate
terminal in rotterdam which is
which is very close to idle at the
moment so it has not much to do with
capacity being in place but with simple
market economics
and prices dictate that lng is not
competitive in europe at the moment and
we think that's going to
last for quite a while at least a number
of years so anyhow this is something
we're working on
and we hope to produce a number of
papers by the end of summer and then
following the course of the fall
i'm turning so my dissertation will will
be published in uh
by routledge this uh this will be next
year i'm handing in my manuscript but
it's about european gas market
integration or the lack thereof
and and what effects that has on
european energy security and then
finally brookings were doing a project
on eastern mediterranean natural gas
which which may be relevant as it is
often mentioned as one of the
alternative sources to russian gas
although i would argue that it's all
pretty preliminary to draw
for any far-reaching conclusions on that
matter so then
on to first energy security in western
europe and i think it's important to
make this distinction between east and
west
as in my debate since i got here in the
united states
it seems to me there's a lot of
misunderstanding about how europeans
view energy security uh and and i think
there's a
in in general uh uh i guess more
appreciation for the eastern
eastern european approach to energy
security uh which he's energy not as a
commodity but also as a security issue
uh in western europe energy resources
are are very much seen as a market issue
something that you can
address by making markets function and i
think they have a good case to make
there
in eastern europe that's different
although at least in words i'm not sure
indeed whether that's the case too but
i'll get that to
back to that in a minute so first in
western europe and
i would include italy there's a large
demand of all the natural gas consumed
in europe 85
is consumed in this part of the market
so it gives you an indication of
relevance
in terms of of demand and yeah
so you have significant market
development you have a lot of
infrastructure storage facilities
lng re-gasification capacity and by and
large very stable relations with russia
i mean energy relations go back a number
of decades and
the larger part of europe has not uh
suffered from any supply disruptions and
has had
uh globally speaking fairly competitive
prices i think the fact
the comparison is sometimes made with
north america and the united states
uh we think that the comparison with
asia is much more relevant as it's the
other large region in the world that
imports a lot of energy resources
and so there would be a much more
sensible comparison the way i see it
so in recent years in northwestern
europe successful market integration
uh partly as a consequence or for to a
large extent as a consequence of
european policies
that i will get back to in a second you
have interconnectors
reverse flow options so gas can flow in
each direction so you're resilient to
potential supply shocks
and and you see now increase up trading
to give an example the about over half
of the volumes that are treated in the
netherlands today
are based on are traded on the hub and
no longer in long-term contracts
and then finally several member states
as you all know are at the forefront of
the
push for a low-carbon economy where
where europe has a
fairly ambitious policy in place for a
number of years
so then we moved to uh let's see eastern
europe
uh where's a different story uh i guess
with the exception of romania say that
demand is insignificant
it's very small even in a large country
like poland uh
consumes only 640 bcf per annum which is
very limited
uh of all the electricity generated in
poland over 90
is coal-fired so natural gas is not very
important
and and so because of this and because
it is not very attractive for market
marketplace to sell their products there
and compete with russia
or with russian gas problem i should say
there's a lack of security of supply
most of these countries have one
supplier there's very limited reverse
flow there's not a lot of investments in
infrastructure and interconnectors and
so on and so forth
and so there's a lack of competition and
obviously that needs to arbitrary
pricing and this is what we've seen in a
number of these states
the the third remark about the european
commission only
partially delivering after 20 2004
prior to the accession of the 10 10 new
member states which were
almost all of them the eastern european
member states in 2004
uh essentially there are always
accession talks about what are we going
to do together how we can work together
and and the the large share of core and
the in the lack of natural gas and the
fuel mix in these countries has was on
the agenda
uh given you know the ambitious climate
policies europe
really wanted these countries to move
away from could their coal use and use
more natural gas
and they were and they were promised
that they were going to be helped with
this um
but you know of course at the end of the
day european commission has very limited
ability to to actually help there has
limited
uh power in terms of
policy making and financial means as
well and so
it could not deliver and this is
something that eastern memphis eastern
european member states
are not pleased about until today so
on the other hand i would say it's very
unclear to me and i
having spent quite a bit of time in
eastern europe and clear to me why
national governments haven't taken more
action themselves
to harness themselves against market
abuse by gasprom
of course this could have been done in
the case of poland uh i've often
wondered why
polish authorities did not invest in
interconnectors with germany so it would
have access to alternative gas
from the netherlands from norway uh
polish authorities even could have
decided to build a pipeline to denmark
would have been far more cheaper than
constructing a multi-billion dollar lng
terminal
which which is now being constructed and
will will come into force later
the effect of these policy decisions is
that
poland will attract alternative supply
but it will be vastly more expensive
than russian gas this will be qatari lng
allegedly sold at about 150 percent of
prices that
russia charges that gas bomb charges in
poland uh and so the polish authorities
will have to regulate these prices
because they don't want their consumers
to pay more at the end of the day now
this is an example of you know what this
is behavior that the way i see it does
not correspond with a
with a country or government that that
sees russia as a serious threat
actions don't match the the the threat
as it is
as it is at least uh portrayed uh and
then finally renewable energy as i'm
sure you all know
is in this part of the continent more
seen as economic harm than anything else
uh and here the security argument which
you can also make for for renewable
energy of course
is apparently not valid um so we'll move
to energy policy where it is today
there have been attempts to uh to to
draft sort of a european energy policy
since the
declaration of messina in 1955 and
well as you all know these attempts have
only had mixed results so far
let's put it like that it's two policy
areas where european commission does
have a significant mandate one and was
touched upon a year by anders
uh market functioning i guess so several
packages
to liberalize electricity and gas
markets were issued
throughout the late 80s the last package
should have been implemented by
by mid-2012 um then
on the other policy area where europe
has a large manner is of course climate
and renewable policy where
uh ambitious policy uh policies are in
place and uh
and uh and and successors are being
discussed and probably decided upon
later today or tomorrow so
only recently and i think this is
important that the european commission
also receive a manner to invest
to better streamline national regulatory
regimes
and to co-invest in energy
infrastructure and the way i see an
energy market you have suppliers and
markets
and you have infrastructure and
regulation and all these factors need to
be need to come in play and
and together can make a market function
now essentially the asynchrony that you
see here in policy making
uh so the european commission having
amanda on market functioning and not
much
on energy infrastructure or streamlining
regulation that asynchrony
i think negatively affects uh eu gas
market electricity market functioning
to date so this is why we are then now
europe essentially being a gas market
under construction and
so there's a difficulty lack of
financial means to invest in so-called
projects of common interest
when this policy proposal was accepted
adopted in 2011
uh 248 projects for energy
infrastructure were listed
and this gives you an indication of the
massive investments that are needed to
make both electricity and gas markets
work
the available budget until 2020 for all
these projects is 5.85 billion euros
which is a fraction really of what is
needed the estimates are that 200
billion euros are needed to make this
work properly
another problem is that existing
legislation is not always implemented
throughout the eu
as an indication of this in late 2012
infringement procedures again 14 member
states were pending
who had not implemented existing
legislation and so you get this
patchwork of national regulatory regimes
uh which is not attractive for suppliers
of course to sell their produce
and makes competition and again this the
emphasis here ought to be on central and
eastern europe makes competition very
difficult unattractive and so it doesn't
happen and you continue to be in a
situation where you have a dominant
supplier
so you need significant market reforms
this regulatory framework continues to
develop and develop and the uncertainty
stays
so in my view market completion will
take a number of more years and not as
the european commission had promised and
and set itself a goal this year
uh it has it will wait for a new
commission and that will come on board
and
to draw to draw a conclusion uh but you
can be fairly certain that that will be
the conclusion
uh so 2014 not realistic at all uh i'll
sum up uh so in light of ukraine i think
what we'll see is an increased interest
in in the projects of common interest
that were mentioned earlier
the list of 248 projects has been
narrowed down to 33 critical projects
may even be a little more money
available who knows will it be enough no
it will not
and second uh the 2030 policy framework
for climate and energy that i referred
to earlier
uh will likely be adopted in some form
although it's highly controversial in
europe
with western europe being ambitious
about this in eastern europe not
um the bottom line is that there will be
probably a 40
carbon reduction target for 20 30 and a
27
renewable energy target uh although you
know these details may uh may change
last minute
but today and tomorrow the european
council is likely to decide about this
possibly the late construction of south
stream we'll see i think eventually it
will get built
and then i finally i guess absent
substantial intervention
uh i think that what remains is uh is
disagreement about who's going to pay
for energy infrastructure in europe
the regulatory uncertainty as i
described will continue will persist
and so i also don't think having seen so
far what i've seen in eastern europe
that
structural reforms will take place price
regulations will be taken away and so on
and so forth
and so i think in that part of the
continent single source dependence will
uh will continue and unfortunately that
market abuse will
uh will will likely be a consequence as
well so i think this is where we are and
again despite absent of substantial and
real into policy intervention
this process of muddling through the way
i see it will continue for a number of
years
thanks thank you tim we'll now hear from
gary hufbar
uh thanks very much and i want to echo
the thanks to ben zeiker who really
organized this
uh this program this morning
so here you have a snapshot of the uh
eia projections of our
production and trade pretty big
increases thanks to the shale revolution
we could become a net exporter of lng by
2016
and sharply reduce our imports of crude
oil
lng exports could range up to 20
million cubic feet a day um
now so that's just kind of a little
picture of the natural gas train you can
see how the imports are declining in a
lot of the
of the lng facilities have been
converted to are
are being converted to uh
exporting as opposed to importing uh
and the trade balance in lmg is
obviously going towards zero
if we look at the crude oil and
petroleum picture
you know it has some echoes of the same
feature
the us has been a a net exporter
of petroleum products for some period of
time not
big numbers but a net exporter this is
gasoline and diesel and aviation fuel
but you can see
that the crude oil negative
position which is a has been a long
feature
of the us economy is slowly
getting less negative so turning to the
regulatory
side of things you've got two
bureaucracies to
tell us whether or not we can export lng
uh the department of energy and the ferc
and i guess there's a fur credit
representative in the room with naughty
so we can toss all the difficult
questions to him
uh there were a lot of applications
submitted to the doe
um under the u.s
legal structure which dates back to the
u.s canada
free trade agreement um
uh any exports to
fta partners are almost automatically
approved but non-fda partners require
sort of a national interest test
there have been seven companies received
kind of conditional public interest test
but only one that chenier has received
the green light from both
uh doe and ferc
that's the lng story um now there's a
a proposal a department of energy
proposal to streamline the licensing
process
um this is quite recent just in late may
they have all these applications to
approve lng exports and uh
they were previously taking them
according to the order in which they
were filed and now
they're supposedly going to prioritize
them to those which are of greater
commercial interest
and give more complete access to the
public
um there's been some
some people think this might be an
improvement might speed things up
others are pretty skeptical the
house is considering a bill which would
impose a
90-day timeline on both on the doe
for reviewing these applications of
course that's just a bill
nothing nothing in law yet
um what about crude oil exports
well um we're now a
leading producer again thanks to the
sale of light crude oil
and these controls on crude oil exports
they go back to the 1970s and the
oil shock everybody recalls that um
right now given that there's a certain
amount of debate on the lng
exports the political appetite for
further liberalizing crude oil
exports is not zero as developments just
the last two days have shown but it's
not
probably as strong so
um in all of that what about the u.s
commitment to
europe well yeah
um you know there's a concerns over
energy dependence on russia there was
some
statement in the march 2014
summit on cooperation and prospects for
lng exports all this talk
is somewhat short of your if you use
hope for a much stronger
declaration let me now expand on this
last point on the cautious
i drafted this before you know the
announcement uh
yesterday or the day before
what rash now can you construct for the
way the obama administration is
operating
on this or anything else but let's just
confine it to lng and
oil uh they
are as far as i can see trying to make
everyone a little bit happy
and no one too mad at them so
in the lng story you have
four competing interests you have the
industrial users
led by dow but there are other companies
as well who would just like to keep lng
in the u.s
because the price will be lower they get
cheaper feedstock
they're happy happy as clams so that's
one
strong pressure group then you have the
environmentalists
who the strong environmentalists are the
most you know
ideologically driven really don't want
anything that
encourages fossil fuel anyway so every
avenue you can use to stop any
development of
fossil fuel of any kind that's a good
thing in their book
so they don't want any lng they don't
want any pipelines they don't want
don't want any of this no one's shale so
that's
group number two then you of course you
have
the uh the gas producers
the shale producers and of course they
want to be able to export to get some of
that
gap between the very low u.s prices and
the very high prices in asia and europe
and then finally of course you have the
uh the european story or the foreign
buyers more generally
before europe it was japan japan really
wanted the us to
it was still once the u.s to liberalize
as does
as do other asian countries and
the these foreign countries and eu in
particular
they want it for the competitive they
want a u.s signal of support and
open markets and so forth which would be
consistent with u.s
trade policy more generally and
consistent with u.s rhetorical support
of europe in the ukraine
crisis but they don't have any illusion
that anything would happen quickly i
mean
even if all the approvals were granted
the conversion of these lng plans takes
a couple of years a couple billion
dollars it's a big thing
long-term contracts transport facility
and so forth
so in the short term what ben zeiker
proposed in terms of coal
the short term being one or two years is
much more practical than some of the
other things that were just mentioned um
but they do like the political signal i
do want the political signal
so these are the four groups which are
competing on lng
and what does the obama administration
do well it gives a little bit to each of
them
uh and that's that's what's happened now
on crude oil
it's pretty much the same story in terms
of the four
competing and the outcome is pretty much
the same
uh the only difference is that here the
uh protective interests which don't want
to export are the refiners
valero particularly you saw the anybody
read the wall street journal you see
their share price dropped by eight
percent
on that notice the notice is not a
complete
blanket approval of crude oil it's just
some kind of
light crude which has some it's a very
low amount of processing gone into it
and
the administration says the commerce
department acted on its own i i doubt
that but i think it's just
kind of uh you know trying to
make everybody a little bit happy and
they made the refiners quite unhappy but
the environmentalists have their same
position of course the oil producers
want and
and europe wants again the signal so
that's where we are in the policy
and um i suppose uh what we see is what
we will get that is
gradual liberalization in the uh
remaining period of the obama
administration nothing
very dramatic unfortunately but uh but
not complete
completely shutting off the export
opportunities
so that's kind of the end of my remarks
but i want to apologize
i have to leave promptly at 12
unfortunately not to watch the game
but i have a previous engagement which
was scheduled long before
we knew the schedule on the game so i
will have to leave but thank you
thank you gary now we'll have gary
schmidt
thanks mark well thank you for hanging
around
at least till 12. um i have
um the dubious honor of going uh last uh
after two uh panels of very fine
presentations and
um it's always hard to find something
else to say when
when so much has already been put on the
table
i'm also i'm also restricted by the fact
that i'm not an economist
and i'm not an energy expert and so
i'm going to try to talk about things
that
overlap with those issues but are done
from a kind of political and perhaps
larger strategic perspective although
again
as the previous panel did a very fine
job of raising those issues as well
um so one of the questions i when i was
thinking about the panel is what
you know what would i say and one option
i want to talk about is
how much europe can help itself when it
comes to
natural gas supplies and there by
reduces dependence on
russian supplies and partially it has to
do with developing their own gas
reserves
which when it comes to just as the
united states
not as large but the truth is
continental europe and
the uk have substantial amount of
shale gas reserves that could
in theory at least reduce dependency if
these reserves were developed
but of course there's a kind of general
pessimism about the ability to
to tap into those reserves um let me go
through a few
examples um of course everybody
remembers a few years ago
there was a great deal of excitement
about polish shale gas
and for a variety of reasons it turns
out that
those reserves are not technically
recoverable in the same
extent that the people thought so you've
gotten a few companies still hanging
around
trying to to tap in
but some of the major companies have
also pulled away
um the germans who have
actually been doing frank fracking for a
number of years
have a ban on shale gas
ranking fracking moving forward that's
part of the
coalition agreement that was settled in
before the
new government took place in in 2013
towards the end in france uh you have
actually
a significant amount of shale gas
potential
i think actually probably the largest
amount in europe
but again the french government is
banned uh tapping into those resources
one would like to think that it's for
you know high reasons of
environmental cause
but in reality it typically has to do
with the fact that france still wants to
be able to sell
nuclear reactors around the world and so
the last thing it wants to do is promote
natural gas exploration and shale gas in
particular
and then ukraine ukraine also has an
immense amount of
shale gas potential but it will not come
to market
until the ukraine is able to to
straighten out its own
domestic uh gas pricing system
which perhaps the imf can help it do
or force it to do but it's going to come
at a great deal of cost because it'll
mean
a very immature very unstable new
government
will be asking a population to take on
higher prices and at a time when
its economy is obviously not doing well
and it won't be doing well for
some time uh in the uk uh
you have a government that actually is
headed towards trying to take advantage
of the shale gas
that resources and reserves that it has
the difficulty in the uk is that the
population is
diametrically opposed and so now you
have this game going on where the
government
is promising all kinds of inducements
building projects for local communities
to be able to bribe them off to so that
they can
so that they can get to the to the gas
uh whether this will actually
come to fruition i think is a very uh
iffy
uh uh proposition
i just happened to come back from london
two days ago and i was talking to a
friend of mine who's a member of
parliament and also a
tory politician who's about as
as as folks here at aei and when i asked
about
the gale the shale gas exploration
issue he said no way over any
everybody's dead body
this is just not going to happen um and
the particular
and the reason is similar to what's also
a problem in in much of europe which is
or all of europe for that matter which
is the minimal rights
uh for the gas belongs to the state and
not individuals and so people
want to know why it is that you're going
to disturb their bucolic
farmland and lifestyle with
with this drilling when they're not
really going to get
any receipts uh revenues
uh from doing so so uh in addition of
course
uh many of these uh countries lack the
infrastructure and
the corporate competitive structure that
we have in the us to be able to pull
all this off so you know can europe help
itself with its own domestic supplies
um i think the answer is um fairly
pessimistic
um now that said and i just wanna and
i'll just very i'm not going to go into
detail because
i thought um i thought tim did a pretty
good job of laying things out
the reality is while the national
governments have been slow
to sort of fix many of their gas supply
problems
the eu commission has done
a decent job again it's been a long
drawn-out process
that began really began in the late
1980s to attempt to liberalize
the energy sector and in the continent
but thankfully or maybe not so
thankfully and from
in 2006 and 2009 and now putin has
given the commission more legitimacy to
push forward
these liberalization um efforts and so
as a result as tim's
noted there's there is a more integrated
market in western europe
uh there's increased storage capacity
interconnectors have been built
uh reverse flow uh gas pipelines is
now possible and lng terminals have been
built
um and as as also was mentioned in the
previous panel the eu commission has
stepped in
um and told bulgaria to stop the the
construction of the south stream
uh pipeline and at least in its
territory
as a violation of eu regulations um
having to do with anti-competition
competition rules
and also of course they want their
they're attempting to investigate the
deals that were cut to build the
pipeline which seemed to go into the
pockets of
friends of mr putin um
but all that said again as tim already
pointed out
central and eastern europe still has
problems when they do
when they've been joining the eu one of
the first things that the eu told them
is you've got to decommission your
nuclear plants
and by the way we have these
environmental rules that we would like
you to follow which means we want you to
get out of
the coal burning business and so the
result was this dependent this greater
dependency on russian gas
so there was the conflict within the eu
itself
over what took priority uh whether it
was climate
issues or energy security and and for
the
at least until recently uh for at least
for central and eastern europe
it's been climate over security
so bottom line it's a mixed picture um
uh there's not much to be done in
helping europe's own production but
the reality is europe is still a very
large
market even though as uh
anders pointed out it's somewhat
stagnant market but it's still a large
market
and if liberalized the
costs energy costs can be reduced and
energy security
uh increased um if this
all happens which again is an open
question there'll be a steady reduction
in
volumes of con contracted gas as these
long-term contracts come up there'll be
less inclination to renew them
and they'll actually be more of a market
for uh spot
gas purchases and you're already seeing
that in the case of
for example the lng terminals are going
to come online this year
with poland and lithuania while it's
true as stem said that
the polish gas that's being imported
from guitar
is connected to oil price index
i think that's only about a third of the
gas the rest of the gas will be spark
market
priced and in the case of lithuania
i think there is no long-term contracts
um i think it's all going to be spot and
the result was that
within because of that the russians
actually have stepped in with
and reduced their own price to the
lithuanians
who were 100 dependent upon russian gas
by about 30 percent
so we're already seeing some impact on
on
russian behavior because of these uh
steps so all the major players see i
think this
situation coming where again we have a
large market
less and less contracts and more spot
but the issue is the first ends will
have a decided advantage with supplies
growing
because once once you're first in and
these supplies natural gas are
increasing it's going to be increasingly
unlikely
that those who follow are going to be
able to
to convince themselves that the
financial risks of these billions of
dollars necessary
to build plants and do the
transportation will be writ will be
worth it because the margins once these
supplies do come online the margins
for shipping lng from the united states
or north america
to europe will obviously decrease and
they will
also decrease for asia as well so
um if you're not first in um it's going
to be harder and harder to convince the
financial people that
there's a play to be made here russia
knows this and this is where i guess i
differ a little bit with tim which is
i'm not so sure
russia at least is so confident that
it's got this market uh
cornered for the next you know in the
out years four or five years from now
because at least the way the russians
are behaving
they're acting as though it's very much
at risk
they're rushing around trying to get new
pipeline deals set
they're moving to try to get into the
asian market to
mitigate whatever more
reduced market they have from europe
they're taking baby steps as anders said
to liberalize their own
gas markets um and they renegotiate
renegotiating pricing um and this also
was suggested they're tossing around a
hell of a lot of cash
to politicians and environmental groups
to hinder this diversification and shale
gas development so
again there's there's obviously some
disagreement about
what russia's position versus vis-a-vis
europe is going to be in the years ahead
but at least for the from the russian
point of view it appears that they're
very much worried about it
so the game is afoot and so how's the
u.s responded
uh well i like the eu it's been a very
much mixed picture as gary i think laid
out
quite well um
i won't repeat the points he's made
mostly because we do want to get out for
the game
but just a couple of small points um
the uh gary mentioned the bill in
congress uh
with h.r six um in fact it passed
uh yesterday afternoon uh and instead of
a 90-day
uh limit on the review process after
the ferc uh decides that it's
environmentally okay for an lng plant to
be big
to be built that got reduced to 30 days
which is really quite remarkable
turnaround if it
if it was actually to become into law in
the senate
you have senators udall and landrieu um
who both are up for reelection and
running
very hard and running very hard
competitive races
they have a version of the bill and they
call for a 45-day
limit to review after ferc approval
now if you take a look at the vote in
the house
while there were i think about 45
democrats who voted for the bill
the overwhelming number of democrats in
the house voted against
uh hr6 so
if you're like me and you've been in
this town for 30 years
you would probably assess that the
chances of the
the udall andrew bill a getting to the
floor
for a vote or probably a small
and and passage uh probably even smaller
so i suppose the good news is that a
year and a half ago
you would not have gotten any of these
bills uh
even to be considered so that's the good
news the bad news
is they're not likely to become law so
we'll be left with an obama
administration as gary
suggested that just a little bit
pregnant about all these matters
now i just wan one final point um
which i'm always kind of struck by maybe
because i'm just not a trade
expert but the current laws that we have
on the back
strike me just on the fair reading of
them as being in violation of our
obligations under the general agreement
on terrorists and trade
the gat particularly article 11 which
prohibits
a discrimination between wto members
about this kind of exporting
you're only allowed to discriminate
for two reasons one is because it's a
natural
natural resource that's exhaustible and
national emergencies
on the exhaustion exemption
you would have to be taking steps to
sort of conserve that
that particular resource but the reality
is we're going great guns
uh producing that that and using that
natural gas
so on its face we're not abiding by
the exception rule and then of course a
national emergency we're not in a
national emergency
um that that commonsensically means that
you're a war or there's a massive crisis
of some sort
so weirdly even though we've gone
and sued china twice now on wto
for doing with rare earths
and metals what we're in fact on the
books
for doing for natural gas we seem to
seem to be remarkably hypocritical about
about this
now the reason why we've won by the way
in those two cases now the reason why
nobody is challenged the u.s obviously
is that our allies are scared to do so
um japan wants our natural gas and the
last thing he wants to do is have pick a
fight about
uh over gad at this particular point in
time it's hoping that the
that these uh seven uh the 14 to 20 or
whatever
lng plants get built um much of that
gas will go to it and south korea
um but nevertheless it would be nice if
at least somebody sued us and to force
open this issue
and i was in europe recently when
the tapes of the polish foreign minister
were released and where he commented
that relation that the translated
relationship with the u.s
for polls was worthless um so
i've i i think i'm going to reach out to
radick and ask him since it is worthless
and
go ahead and start suing us so we can
get this game
afoot uh more strongly when it comes to
exporting
uh lng to europe and asia thanks
thank you gary uh before we open it up
for questions does anybody on the panel
want to offer any additional
comments or reactions
okay all right well let's open it up for
questions then
please state your name and your
affiliation
okay i'm adam gustafson at boyd and
grain associates
i'm interested in this problem gary that
you've identified between
this divergence between u.s policy where
the land owner owns the the rights
underneath his land and
the european policy which is the
opposite and i'm wondering
if there have been any ideas or
proposals to
to change that it sounds like in the uk
it's been
more community oriented with these
building projects you've described but
i wonder if there's been anything more
landowner
oriented or if you have any proposals
i i've literally not seen anybody i mean
when i bring this up
you know they they're all my european uh
politician friends just nod and it's
just that's
you know that's true and then and then
you ask them whether or not
there's any likelihood that they could
ever uh change the law on that
and they nod and go this way so
um i just haven't seen anything i mean
in the uk it's just i mean
you know those of you who've you know
walked
you know variety of you know uh paths in
the
in in england you realize you know so
even if a farmer has a
you know a piece of land everybody's
tromping across it hiking
um and sort of just the land is thought
to be
sort of even though you know property
rights are
his um there's a kind of a communal
sense that you
that the thing belongs to everybody or
or in this case
mineral rights belong to the crown
exactly but um but i've seen no progress
on it and even
for countries that were that are like
poland which are
at least in theory were originally more
market oriented and
just made no made no effort to change
this
at all
laura mercilesi us's area network so
socar which is the azerbaijani state oil
company as i'm sure you know is supposed
to complete
its 10th pipeline from baku to
europe by the end of this year actually
and i'm wondering
what you think the repercussions will be
on the natural gas market in europe
specifically with regards to russia's
stake
and what the repercussions might be
political or otherwise in the caucus
region
so the the tap pipeline you said right
yes
yeah okay so well i mean the the initial
capacity i think the first
uh uh supplies are actually expected in
2018
uh but but maybe they come earlier the
the capacity initially is 10 bcm uh
so i beg your pardon i mean
no so well okay no the the initial
capacity is 10 bcm and there
there are plans that it may be upgraded
if market
you know forces would allow it to 30 and
the but but it's all theoretical what we
have is 10 bcm that is contracted and
will flow from 2018.
uh that is that is a very welcome and
helpful supply of course
it doesn't change the gas market in
europe fundamentally
one one footnote gas though is also
going to be
price is going to be tagged to the oil
price
and so in that sense it's in terms of
economics it's not all that much more
helpful when it comes to
to reducing
costs and again it won't be as well if
it
remains tied to the oil the idea that it
could be expanded i think is going to be
less
likely because by that time there will
be a lot more spot oil
on the international market
somebody mentioned the mediterranean
mediterranean fields
you can use the mic oh yeah bronco
teresa again
somebody one of you mentioned the
mediterranean fields i think you're
talking about
tamar and leviathan off of the off of
cyprus
what are the time frames for that and at
one time there was talk about a nabucco
line
nobody talks about that anymore is that
dead
uh so the the
the estimate so the needs of
mediterranean offshore israel two
significant fields have been found tamar
is producing uh i think it's about 10 or
12
uh tcf if i'm not mistaken leviathan is
a little bigger uh it's not on stream
actually the uh the company the
australian company that was interested
to that was looking into whether they
could reach an agreement to export lng
from that part of the world
pulled out uh and is not staying and the
i was in israel just last week
came back last thursday and uh
policymakers have shifted interestingly
their
thoughts about selling this in as lng to
exploring regional options which makes
much more sense economically of course
uh if if only the politics would allow
for a pipeline to be built which is
which is not a given this part of the
world but i think
i would expect that in due time some
form of agreement with turkey could be
reached there's a lot of private sector
interests on both sides to do this
and what i understand is that if i mean
erdogan is in a difficult spot now with
the presidential election cycle but once
that's
over it's not unlikely that there will
be some form of agreement
but you would have to construct a
subsidy pipeline still because he can't
go through syrian lebanon
making it more expensive challenging and
and it has to go through a cypriot eez
which is of course another issue that
needs to be addressed then so i think
all in all there is there's promise
there's supplies there's
some supplies offshore cyprus as well of
course although
uh those are i think all in all my my
conclusion now would be they're
regionally
potentially very significant if if these
states can
somehow collaborate and share their
their resource um
some of it may go to europe but i think
that
well i think that the expectations of
that are
are are somewhat inflated and uh it
remains to be seen how much is really
competitive in europe and in the
timeframe
we're talking you know not by the end of
this decade at the earliest
uh and as for and as for nabucco uh i
think that i mean it was competing of
course
with the top ten up uh project um
you know it was a politically uh
politically motivated pipeline
it went through areas where which we
talked about that have the
the least interconnection uh that are
most vulnerable to
to supply disruptions um and uh but the
markets are very small and so
i'm i was not that surprised that market
forces dictated that taptana would be
more
interesting to bring that gas to italy
which is which is actually a large
market
makes much more sense commercially and
so i don't think that there's a lot of
a lot of hope that nabucco will get
built
anybody else
well i guess we can uh maybe close out
early thanks again to
tim and gary and gary and thanks again
to ben zeiker for
helping put this together and uh thank
you for coming to aei